[Music]
spaces
influence me in how they affect your
feeling on the inside
[Music]
from churches to you know
auditoriums to theaters there's a sense
of grandness in them
i try to harness emotions in my work
through
the type of materiality
and form that i tend to try and curate
within their structures this is also
through
color and through lighting and the
synergy between all those
different elements the shri krishna
temple the
colors on the facade of this temple
they're just
they're stunning pastel hues
but they're yet so punchy and i love
that
blue base they're using um
every time i walk by stop and take
photos so the
sai baba temple is a landmark
i'm really drawn to the facade itself is
very simple
but the combination of colors along with
just the curves along with the kind of
linearity
it has a kind of retro feel to it
the mirror balls at empress place is a
really good example of
how objects are integrated within
a specific environment and how they
speak
to the audiences that move around them
the
marina bay sands mirror facade is very
compelling because it uses
kinetic forces to generate ever-changing
appearances
it reflects the exact state of its
environment
and how it reflects also the light
is something that i find really
beautiful the reason why i also
enjoy looking at window display is
because
these are actually mini sets
[Music]
making the emotional connection is key
to creating a unique retail space this
encourages
the consumer to return for that repeat
experience
what i really love about that his
installation at the marina bay sands is
is the cleanliness of of the materiality
that he uses um
the placement and how it speaks you know
and sits within the environment you know
among the the the
pool of lilies and how it reflects the
sky
the way they have worked with the
particular material
you know the stainless steel how do you
bend it you know how do you install it
the technicalities of it is what i find
really interesting
cloud forest is on an architectural
scale it's just got this grandness to it
it's like this futuristic greenhouse
once you step inside what i'm really
drawn to is that
fresh air just kind of like slams your
face
[Music]
i i will always spend a fair bit of time
um observing how audiences interact with
the with the work itself
the the type of tool sets i like to use
within the work
includes a lot of reflective finishes
such as mirror
and lighting i love to use mirror
because it's a good opportunity to
completely transform a space into
something completely different
we like to play with optical illusions
we like to play with depth
and repetition i also really like
symmetry which is why we tend to use a
lot of symmetrical
linear forms using mirror and light are
great mediums
to disrupt the environment expanding the
space
keeping the audiences engaged my
intended audience experience
when using these elements is to explore
the notion of space that sits between
art and architecture
through creating worlds made up of
visuals light and sounds
i hope to generate a form of catharsis
it was a time when i was still working
as an interior designer i was
not feeling very inspired i actually
started just messaging friends on
facebook next thing you know
a friend of mine who was working at zuk
he was like hey they're looking for a
set designer come in for an interview
when the role for set design came up i
was like well what is set design exactly
all i knew is that i wanted to create
art and i wanted to follow my dreams
what i did
wanted when i was a kid and that's what
happened and that's that's when it
[Music]
started
you